I have noticed that the more from like
Tokyo southwards people are more fun
more North not so fun oh you think so
people are way more chilled the more
south you go in Japan yeah I mean yeah
south I mean I guess West yeah west and
south way more chill Southwest yeah yeah
because you start going to like Tokyo
people get more chill also like are
super chill super outgoing and then
people get more chill and then you shoot
people are really chill yeah well
everyone is really willing to talk
really outgoing so if more North you go
the less willing but people in Hokkaido
do not want to talk no no so I feel like
it's it's kind of yeah she's kind of
like more West yeah
I've noticed it's like like even
Japanese they don't really want to reach
other Japanese you know they really
don't want to talk I've just noticed I
want to die it's such a weird cultural
difference I don't know if it's like the
coals makes people not want to talk
I think it is the weather I don't want
to open my mouth
I'm gonna speed I'm going to speak from
my experience at least whenever you go
to a country that is more known for like
water climber things just move slower
right I think so yeah things move slower
and but like the the offset of that is
that people will just see more chill you
know I'll never forget what you said
about Australia when you went you were
like it's like the UK but everyone's
happy yeah yeah I mean it's true it's
true though it's like it's interesting
yeah it's probably it's probably the
weather to be honest yeah the weather
certainly helps yeah I mean like maybe
but it's like there are some parts of
like like Southwest uh Japan where it's
like the weather is not that great right
so me I'm sure the weather is a fast but
it might be like some kind of like
actual cultural route of spending
however many generations that is just
ingrained into the the local culture
there I don't know it's like two shoes
really chill everybody is everyone
everyone talked to yeah just Vibes yeah
a lot more outgoing profound than than
when we were in al-Qaeda it was like the
complete opposite yeah do not want to
talk no no well I feel like Hokkaido
especially during the winter it's just
like you every man for themselves yeah
you have to make your time is more it
felt like they were more open to it in
winter because it was like more touristy
right when I was there in summer it was
like completely different vibe where
they were just like what do you hear get
out you know welcome here get out
I don't know that's not that bad but you
just feel like no one wants to talk
which is fine I'm not gonna be like hey
let's talk but it's like even just like
little conversations you know maybe the
combini like you know when I went to
Starbucks in case you requests the
people were way more talkative asking
questions oh yeah yeah what are you up
to and it's like oh this doesn't happen
yeah Tokyo bro I mean there's no time
for that [ __ ] in Tokyo everyone's like
get out get your food Ramen [ __ ] off eat
it in Okinawa everyone [ __ ] talks to
you oh yeah like it's like you could be
in the middle of the [ __ ] forest and
they'll just be like so what are you up
to today I was like oh I'm not used to
this hold on
yeah it's great Vibes yeah
um yeah especially like tropical
climates you know okinawan's like
tropical climate I can see that but I'm
betting I'm betting it's very hard to
get [ __ ] done there that's yeah just not
a not a whole lot happens over there but
that's but that's kind of like why I
like
I I know we're making a full circle here
but like I feel the most like Slice of
Life anime experience when I'm in
Okinawa oh dude because nothing happens
there but I like the fact that nothing
happens there it's it's it kind of
military
but like it kind of moves at its own
time where it's like it's like you know
you could be going through the whole day
in Okinawa doing nothing you you walk
around even in the city in like naha and
everyone's just kind of like
vibing like no one's it doesn't seem
like anyone's like busy or like you know
on the clock or anything like that or
like stressed out everyone's just like
yeah we're just here we're just just
chilling just living our life you're
doing good bro all right sick yeah it's
like [ __ ] well you know it's just like
that's that's the vibe I get and it's
like because I remember when we stayed
uh when we went to our friend's place uh
who lives in all you know whose parents
live in Okinawa yeah and it's like the
most like [ __ ] traditional Japanese
house ever right like just like
literally the [ __ ] you see in like
non-numburi like Slice of Life [ __ ] it's
that kind of house and I remember just
like while I was in that house
everything just moved really slowly and
I didn't care about what time it was or
what we were doing we were just like
chatting and chilling in the living room
and just like you know my friends like
Dad like collects all this suck and he
was just like showing us all this [ __ ]
I'm like I you know it's not like I was
like super engrossed in what he was
talking about but it was like you know
what I I [ __ ] with this this is kind of
nice and I don't know why I like that
because you guys have like a sanctuary
some place you go to that
surely that's yours you spend [ __ ] 19
in your life ain't no way it's the
toilet for you you [ __ ] speed run
that [ __ ] with those ten minutes
this [ __ ] like I'll see you
next year when he's on the toilet yeah
no I'm I'm talking about the toilets
like the hyperbolic times I'll see you
in 20 years I'm talking about like a
place that you can go to and it's always
going to be like the same it's always
going to give you like Comfort whenever
you need to like take a break or
something like that it can can be like
Parks can be Parks
I don't know to me it's not necessarily
the place it's more like how I'm what
I'm feeling and what I'm doing as
opposed to the place I feel like then if
I put too much weight on a place and
then it changes or whatever I'll be like
no that's that's the thing right because
that's the reason I brought it up
because I know a few people have like
their own Sanctuary most of the time
it's their home especially if you've you
know moved out your country with their
house your Sanctuary is kind of like
your home and I'm wondering if you guys
have ever had that moment where you're
just like really looking forward to
coming back home come to a place you
haven't been to for a long time but
you've valued for a long time and then
something small changes and you're like
I hate it I hate it how dare this small
thing change even though that's the
natural course of Life yeah like how
dare my favorite restaurant near my
house like [ __ ] clothes and you're
like how like it like nothing hurts more
like perfect like yeah so like my
grandma's house for example in Japan is
like a great example of that I haven't
been back since she moved before the
pandemic started yeah and when I say she
moved I literally mean she moved from an
apartment that was like here to the
apartment literally across the road so
in terms of local area nothing has
changed right but I'm going back like at
the end of the month so you know to
celebrate New Years and I'm just
dreading I'm like it's the same but it's
not the same something something about
this is not the same not the same even
though it is the same and it's just like
it's still in this it's still in the
same town it's literally across the road
like if I wanted to go to the old
apartment it's like a 30 second walk
it's right there but I'm I'm just
dreading there's a part of me that's
dreading where I'm just like
it's not gonna be like it was before
wasn't it and yeah especially going to
your Grandma's place that's something
that always felt like it never changed
like your grandparents place that was
always that was always the same [ __ ]
when you're a kid growing up teenager
yeah I like my Grandma's place in
Australia That's My Sanctuary because
I'm like that [ __ ] hasn't changed in
like 50 years yeah he's been living
there her whole life I'm like that's
good but my grandma here I'm just like
you've changed
how dare you change maybe I'm weird I
always liked you when it changed I was
like really you're you're upgrading or
you're changing things yeah that's cool
I like that but don't you feel like I
don't know don't you feel like you'd
lose like even a little bit of like that
Nostalgia yeah and I mean yeah sure but
like does that I mean for me it's like I
don't really I don't really mind it's
whatever Nostalgia types of people man
Nostalgia is overrated I [ __ ] love
him
yeah yeah yeah that's what I gave game
devs have been milking us dry with
Nostalgia dude with the dog [ __ ] remake
that's why they're powering they're
taking that and shoving it back in
if you never look back you can never
tell how far you've gotten man
nostalgia's [ __ ] man like
Nostalgia looking back or is it is it or
is it missing or wanting that Feeling
Again of it it's a bit of both I'd say
yeah
I'm retrospective I don't think it's
it's looking but I think Nostalgia is
like a combination of things it's it's
the whole looking back and being like ah
you remember the good old days but also
it's the looking back and being like I
remember my not not where the world was
at that point in time but where I was in
that point yeah yeah yeah and it's like
sometimes you don't miss that [ __ ]
sometimes you're like I'm glad I'm an
adult now with expandable income and I
can do whatever the value I want yeah
right whatever I want but there's a part
of me that also misses you know my
granddad buying me ice cream at the
local [ __ ] store yeah you know after
school and stuff like that like that oh
I I miss the [ __ ] out of that
why my brain don't do that I don't know
I don't know why my brain don't like it
your brain is just constantly upgrading
dude I think so I'm like upgrade upgrade
upgrade the new upgrade comes
amazing memory progress must be made Sea
Dog
103.51 now installing new drives drivers
hold on patching myself
fixing bugs and glitches